Samuel leaves here and I'd like to say
the four things which would guarantee
you to be successful in your property
investment journey I would say these
four things number one is to learn go
ahead and learn what you need to do to
be successful
number two is to believe believe that
you can do this if you even if you learn
all the things to do you don't believe
you can do it
you don't have faith in yourself in a
faith in the system then you probably
will be right you won't be able to learn
number three is to implement you can
learn and you can even believe but
unless you actually do you're not going
to be successful and then lastly number
four is to be creative you see you're
gonna have gaps whether that gap might
be hunger the money
you haven't got the the knowledge you
haven't got the at the time you haven't
got the resources you haven't got the
inclusion you haven't got the power team
so you need to be creative and to
invention people and put those things in
place so learn believe implement and be
creative on this video I'm just going to
say a couple things about the best
places best resources and best ways how
you can learn all you need to to be
successful in property so in order to
get all the information that you need to
be successful in property again there's
four ways you can get absolutely
everything you need to know and learn
everything you need to learn so the
first one is books Jim Rohn says that
we're only a book away from knowing
anything we want and well that's not
completely true because there are things
that you can't learn in books so it's a
really good point especially if you've
not got a lot of money there's some
seriously good books out there with so
much information and the great thing
about a book is you can get an absolute
trashy romance book and a book like my
book by low rent high on property and
then the same price because books always
sell for about ten fifteen pounds so get
yourself some good books on property the
thing is if you got just to go into
Amazon and type in property investing
there's loads of books of course I'd
recommend mine I'm biased by lower and
high but that's a really good way you
can learn comfort of your own home at
your own pace highlight a pen and learn
from books next why is to learn from
other people now you know you can just
find people that are successful and ask
them questions you'll be amazed at the
response you'll get most people are
generally good and like to help you and
if you say if you find someone that's
accessible in an area in property and
you just say to them hey you're pretty
successful can ask you a couple
questions or can I take you out for a
coffee it's a fantastic waste what I did
in the early days by the way
disclaimer if you ask me to come out for
a coffee I'm gonna say no because the
reason is that's why I run the property
investors crash course but in fact in
the very first place the reason I put
the crash course on was because I
couldn't keep up with all the coffee's
and dinners people were taking me out
for so that's why I ran it in the first
place
but find people that just a little bit
ahead of you in their property
investment journey and say hey Cassie
some questions learn from other people
number three learn from going on
training programs I'm a massive advocate
for training programs someone said to me
you're only an advocate for training
programs because you run them they're an
idiot the truth is I run them because
I'm an advocate for them myself in the
last two years I've spent just shy of
two hundred thousand pounds on my own
training ongoing on courses on investing
in mentors massive advocate for that the
best investment you can make even bigger
than property is yourself because if you
mess with yourself no can ever take that
from you so I'd say if you've got 20
grand I'd be inclined to put that 20
grand in myself first before in property
because you put it in property you buy
one house great then what what next you
put it in yourself you learn how to buy
ten houses so it makes sense to do that
so go on good programs there's a lot of
good training programs out there again
I'm biased but the property investors
crash course has the highest results in
the country for successful investors
from what I've studied I'd be happy to
prove wrong so go on programs then
lastly you can learn fourthly from your
own mistakes now that's the most
expensive way to learn I can't remember
who it was that said if you think if you
think education is expensive you should
try mistakes so it's very expensive but
still you are going to make mistakes
because you're not gonna learn
absolutely everything there was to know
about property and about investing by
books talking to people and seminars and
training programs so so when you make a
mistake rather than seeing it as a
failure see it as an opportunity to
learn write it down make your own book
over the years you should have a book
filled with your mistakes which you
celebrate because you turn them into
lessons so read box talk to people that
are slightly ahead of you attend
training programs and lastly learn from
your own mistakes write them down so I
hope that's been helpful look forward to
seeing you next time god bless thank you
so much for watching if you benefited on
that video please do share it with your
family and friends for more videos like
it you can watch right here and if you'd
like to spend two days with me at the
property investors crash course watch
this video see what happens but whatever
you do don't forget to subscribe right
here and I'll see you next time